the show opens up with some students of
sungyan High School playing football
While others are studying in the
classroom at the same time a lot of
mysterious spheres are seen floating and
covering up the whole city after class
two students kim chi Yol and Kim diak
Joon discussed the strange alien spheres
that have been hovering in the sky for
about a year here we get to know that
numerous scientists conducted research
on the Spheres and came to the
conclusion that they are not harmful to
humans no one knows where it came from
but the people are at least relieved to
know that they are not dangerous as they
walk away Chi Yul tries to talk to Young
Hoon the top student who gets bullied a
lot but remains resilient unfortunately
young Hoon ignores him and heads home on
the bus on the way he watches a YouTube
show discussing the Spheres and the
rumors surrounding them meanwhile the
military inspects a fallen sphere and
here we are introduced to Lee one of the
prominent soldiers their Commander soon
arrives and orders the soldiers to shoot
at the ball but when it does no damage
He suggests using an RPG G missile as
soon as the soldier shoots at the sphere
a loud bang is heard then some purple
creatures start emerging from it
elsewhere after their usual four-week
break the students returned to school
and immediately resume their typical
Antics and rivalries their homeroom
teacher Park un young distributes report
cards but before she can begin the
lesson she is called away when un young
returns she seems uneasy and delivers
the news that early college admissions
have been canceled the top students in
the class are worried and confused while
the dumbasses are happy and relieved
despite the teacher's efforts to
continue with the lesson the students
begin to murmur among themselves and the
classroom becomes restless the teacher
then turns on the TV and the student's
watch is the Minister of Defense
addresses the nation the minister
announces a national mobilization which
mandates the drafting of even third
grade high school students into the
military everyone is shocked by this
news but the minister reassures them
that education will still be prioritized
and they will receive extra credit it
for College admission after this the
teacher explains to the students that
only those who participate in military
training will receive extra credits
after she leaves the military arrives at
the school to prepare for the training
the next morning the students arrive at
school with their favorite belongings
including makeup and non-essential items
that they think they cannot live without
the teacher then introduces first
lieutenant Lee as the class platoon
leader as the briefing begins Lee
informs everyone that the training will
take place after regular classes he also
explains that from this day forward the
students will undergo military training
for several weeks and will not be
allowed to leave the school environment
Yu Jiang the class president is
immediately appointed as the leader
while Chi Yol is tasked with documenting
everything during the training any
student who goes against the Commander's
orders will face a point deduction as
well as a penalty after the explanation
Sergeant Juan bin directs the students
to their respective dormitories they put
away their belongings and immediately
gather to undergo training in the
schoolyard in the next scene the
soldiers distribute Firearms to the
students but some Express doubts about
being trusted to handle them a few try
to Showcase their experience with online
games and start playing around with the
guns soon after Lieutenant Lee arrives
and restores Order among the students he
then punishes the guilty ones making
them run until they are completely
exhausted surprisingly despite the
grueling training some female students
fall for the Lieutenant's charm and
become captivated by his Luke's after a
while the students returned to their
Barracks completely broken and tired
during the record-keeping some leave
messages for their parents feeling
deceived by The Experience While others
cry out for their mothers later that
evening a boy named IL ha shares a video
of the military shooting and killing
animals mercilessly diak Jung speculates
that mass killings only occur if there
is a virus spread in the city or in the
event of a war while they discussed this
young Hoon tries to leave the room but
the noise attracts Lieutenant Lee's
attention he admonishes young Hoon for
trying to leave alone and in response
the latter reveals that IL ha brought
his phone to the training hearing this
Lieutenant Lee confiscates ilha's phone
making him angry as a result he becomes
vengeful towards jung-hoon and the two
almost come to blows Lieutenant Lee
immediately intervenes and sends them
outside his punishments but even there
they continue arguing fortunately she
all arrives and manages to defuse the
situation before it escalates further
just then a giant sphere suddenly falls
on the school building Landing in front
of the three students but instead of
reporting it they continue arguing and
In the Heat of the Moment Kwan ilha
pushes young Hoon toward the sphere
shockingly the sphere transforms into a
monstrous creature resembling an octopus
that entwines jung-hoon's body and
devours him alive a terrified sheol
attempts to approach the creature but
right then Lieutenant Lee arrives at the
scene and stops him after this the
creature retracts into the shape of a
ball and goes away from there contrary
to popular belief that octopus was not
sexy later when the homeroom teacher
Miss un young learns of young
death she is devastated she nervously
suggests sending all the remaining
students home but lieutenantly informs
her that he has received orders to keep
the truth under wraps and to take
appropriate military action he urges
Yoon young to persuade the students to
keep quiet about young hoon's death so
that Panic doesn't instill with no
options left ilha and she you'll also
agree to lie about young hoon's
disappearance telling their classmates
that he was badly injured and sent home
as the school returns to normal it
becomes clear that the sphere was not
the only threat facing them the
government and Military are trying to
hide something even more dangerous and
the students find themselves caught up
in a deadly conspiracy elsewhere
Lieutenant Lee is haunted by a painful
memory of what happened to his division
when they encountered his fear while
using an RPG gun the sphere exploded and
Unleashed a vicious attack resulting in
the loss of many lives the following
morning curiosity arises among the
students who wonder about the mysterious
sphere that fell in the school building
the previous night however ilhan shioler
still saddened by the incident so they
don't speak a word in response to the
sphere falling dangerously close to the
school military commander Park young IL
calls for intensifying the students
training including firearm use and
self-defense although Lieutenant Lee is
initially hesitant he realizes the
necessity of the decision the students
also get on board with the plan and
start attending their new classes as
expected the firearm training proves to
be challenging for most but not for a
brave girl named Lee Nara she handles
the weapons with ease firing them
accurately at the Target as the days
pass the training continues with the
students recording messages for their
parents and learning essential
life-saving skills like CPR gradually
they adjust to their new normal while
Chi Yul starts harboring a crush on Nara
one night cheol has a nightmare and
seeks comfort from Lee narai in the
classroom afterward they both return to
their Barracks leaving XI yol's growing
feelings for Nara more evident than
before in the next scene Lieutenant Lee
checks on the sphere that fell on the
school grounds it turns out that the
military has covered it with a hollow
Dome and froze in it but they still know
very little about the sphere the
following morning do students prepare to
leave the school premises to practice
shooting with real bullets as they walk
the streets they are surprised to find
them empty not a single person is
visible as far as the eye can see after
a while the training begins and the
sound of gunfire initially scares the
students but they soon adapt as expected
Nara performs exceptionally well hitting
the targets with the utmost confidence
everyone is impressed by her performance
and she also receives praise from the
soldiers lady you're a good hot I mean a
good uh thought of the shot on their way
back Lieutenant Lee hears a sudden noise
coming from the distance so he orders
everyone to stay together and wait
however using this opportunity two brats
decide to visit a convenience store they
passed on the way for snacks on arriving
there they find the place deserted South
they quickly grabbed some snacks that
they had been craving for When teacher
Park un young finds out about this she
takes charge and quickly communicates
with the soldiers search for the missing
students right then another student Kook
young Soo gives her a lead that the
brats might have gone to the nearby
convenience store so without wasting any
time unyong rushes to find them along
with a senior student Kim Yoo Jung
meanwhile Lieutenant Lee and Sergeant
Kim Wong bin notice a large crater made
by the sphere and get worried there is
also a trail of Blood on the ground so
the two follow it to investigate
meanwhile you Jung notices a gun lying
beside the road but when she tries to
pick it up she finds a chopped hand
holding it out of fear she screams
loudly alerting the teacher and other
students un young then proceeds to
follow the trail of blood and after a
while she discovers the strange
creatures with tentacles and the dead
bodies of students from other schools
shocked and horrified she screams for
the kids to run startled by the chaos
around the creatures suddenly come alive
and start attacking the group teacher
parkun young grabs a gun and shoots
randomly at the creatures to protect its
students but she eventually runs out of
bullets and gets killed by one of them
another soldier who comes to their aid
is decapitated by the Spheres leaving
the students with no choice but to flee
as they run through the streets they
come across more dead bodies and spheres
despite the chaos and confusion the
soldiers urged the students to keep
moving and not give up however some
students like Hana are overwhelmed with
fear especially after witnessing the
death of their teacher she locks herself
inside a car refusing to let her friends
inside fortunately Sergeant Kim Won bin
is able to reunite most of the kids but
they still worry about the fate of those
who are missing elsewhere we see the
brats enjoying a modest Feast at the
convenience store oblivious to the chaos
unfolding outside as they prepare to
leave they spot one of the mysterious
creatures and begin playing with it
unaware of the Grave danger it possesses
their playful attitude quickly
dissipates though as it attacks them
abruptly making them realize that the
sphere is not as harmless as it seemed
following this an intense fight ensues
as the brats struggle to keep the
themselves alive in the end however they
somehow managed to trap the creature in
the freezer to their shock it becomes
inactive under cold temperatures and
eventually dies meanwhile the other
students are also fighting for survival
supporting each other and battling the
strange monster creatures they
eventually reunite under the leadership
of Lieutenant Lee and Kim Won bin but
they're shaken to the core by what they
have seen later all of them gather at a
place and Kim Won bin updates
lieutenantly on the casualties and hands
him a watch belonging to a Dead Soldier
he also reveals that he has given the
students three bullets each to shoot at
the creatures after this lieutenantly
addresses the students explaining that
the Spheres are what he has been
preparing them to fight against suddenly
he senses movement and leads the
students with their weapons at the ready
only to discover that it's the two brats
following this a flashback reveals
Lieutenant Lee's past and how he
initially objected to the military's
plan to draft high school students But
ultimately agreed to train them and give
them a Fighting Chance in the present as
the students are arrive at their
classroom Hana apologizes to her friends
for not opening the door earlier however
the students are in a state of panic
with some of them hastily packing their
belongings to leave Hana tries to calm
them down but their fears have already
taken hold fortunately Lieutenant Lee
arrives and commands them to sit down he
reminds them that it's dangerous at side
and that school is the safest place to
be he also stresses that this is the
only place where they can train to
defend themselves however after he
leaves the students decide to vote on
whether to stay or go home all of them
except young Soo vote to leave this is
because he still wants to appear for the
military test so that he can get extra
credit points unfortunately this only
angers the bully IL ha and he starts a
fight with young seal as all this is
happening most of the students feel like
the adults are manipulating them causing
them to feel frustrated and Powerless
they vote again but youngsu still
chooses to remain behind so ilha loses
his temper and viciously attacks him
once again after the tense voting you
Jung and young Shin the student leaders
meet with Lieutenant Lee to discuss the
situation however the latter drops a
bombshell that there is no home for them
to go back to he reveals that their
parents are most likely in a shelter and
finding them will be near impossible
right now the lieutenant then emphasizes
that they are now soldiers in a war and
as such they cannot afford to leave
hearing this news the other students are
overwhelmed with anger and sadness that
night the training resumes and
lieutenantly pushes the students to the
point of exhaustion some of them even
break down and plead that they cannot
continue anymore later as the students
are lamenting their situation Sergeant
Kim Won bin reassures them that they are
doing everything to get rid of the
creatures meanwhile Lieutenant Lee goes
to inspect the sphere that landed on the
school grounds and recalls how the
military tried to create weapons that
could destroy them after countless trial
and error they discovered that only
depleted uranium ammunition can destroy
the small spheres Unfortunately they did
not have enough ammunition or soldiers
which is what led to the recruitment of
high high school students for the fight
against the Spheres after dinner the
students hold a meeting to discuss their
escape plans their first order of
business is to send a group to confirm
whether their parents have been taken to
a shelter XI Yol who lives closest to
the school is chosen along with some
other boys later they try to execute
their plan but their attempt to sneak
out is thwarted when soldiers spot them
and a long Chase ensues before they are
eventually apprehended in response to
the attempted Escape Lieutenant Lee
punishes all of them emphasizing that
they are now soldiers not privileged
students he warns them that desertion
will result in a court martial and
execution after this the students return
to their Barracks humiliated and angry
however they are still not ready to give
up on their Escape Plan during a protest
after lunch Commander Park young ill and
his soldiers attempt to Halt the
student's Exodus he pulls out a gun and
fires a warning shot while Lieutenant
Lee arrives to remind the students about
the significance of the upcoming
Scholastic test however they remain
unyielding refusing to be swayed by the
promise of credit points in the of this
commotion a sphere suddenly drops
triggering a frenzied attack despite
Lieutenant Lee's attempts to urge the
students back to their classrooms it is
too late the Spheres have already
descended upon them the soldiers fight
valiantly to fend off the assault while
also safeguarding the students
tragically most of the students are
unable to escape the onslaught despite
their efforts to assist one another
Commander Park young IL chooses to
abandon his men and flees in his car
only to mean a gruesome fate as chaos
ensues and more deadly spheres rain down
upon them yujung takes charge and
mobilizes some of the students to make a
run for the classrooms Sergeant Juan bin
despite his best efforts is unable to
save a fellow comrade while young Shin
somehow manages to find his girlfriend
and keep her safe thankfully Nara proves
to be a skilled and fearless Soldier as
she grabs a gun and shoots down the
dangerous spheres with Incredible
accuracy her bravery saves many lives
and inspires the others to keep fighting
with the situation becoming increasingly
Danger dangerous Lieutenant Lee and
Sergeant Juan bin strategize on how to
lead the students to safety they arm the
kids and order them to grab their gear
from the barracks giving clear
instructions and explaining their Exit
Plan left with no choice the students
follow their lead running towards the
ground floor while Nara provides cover
for them after a while they reach the
military cars outside and lieutenantly
orders them to run towards the trucks
Nara continues to provide cover as the
students arm themselves and take aim at
any threats sadly not everyone makes it
to the truck in time as a few students
are left behind the episode ends with
Lieutenant Lee managing to stop the
truck just in time for sergeant Juan bin
to jump on and drive off to
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching